I was gonna tell you a little bit about
uh something called Model driven
engineering which is a subfield in
software engineering uh so it's about
developing software about uh an
interesting new way different way of
developing software
so let me perhaps say a little bit about
this idea of abstraction for us because
that's been around in computer science
for ages computers really only know
zeros and wants that doesn't really work
for humans right so thinking through a
problem in zeros and ones is really
really difficult
so what have we done well we started
building a language on top of that right
originally there's a language where he
said well there's certain commands that
the computer can do these commands we
can encode as a number that means we can
encode them using zeros and once so
sequence of those numbers becomes a
program we kind of went okay well that's
a little difficult still right I still
have to think of these numbers so we
started using something called assembly
which is a slightly higher level
language it's essentially taking those
number codes unassigning a word to each
one so we now write rather than writing
seven we write at that's still
complicated because you've got to write
out every single little step and
everything in there and So eventually
people started developing what they
called higher level programming
languages things like Fortran C plus
plus Java these kinds of languages and
what they do is they give us a language
that much more readable and much more
writable much more understandable to
a well-trained human being there's still
a problem with that okay which is you've
got to be a technically trained person
to use these languages because what
these languages are doing is they're
allowing you to express a problem and a
solution to the problem that you have in
terms of a computer so you've got to say
computer do this computer do that now do
this
but actually the problem that you had
was
I want to manage bank accounts I want to
manage mortgages
I want to simulate cell biology
I you know problems that the computer
doesn't have a clue about basically so
in the programmer's head there needs to
happen a lot of translation from these
domain specific Concepts
into something that explains them to the
computer
and all of that translation gets lost
maybe let me try and show that to you a
little bit in in in a simple example
what I have here is a simple development
environment as many software developers
will uh will use in this day-to-day work
and I've written a simple program in
Java that allows me to
play Minesweeper games now depending on
your age you may or may not know what
Minesweeper is so I've brought it up
here as an example it was this sort of
game I think it was came with with
pretty much all the old computers and
where you've got this sort of
rectangular grid here and each element
on the grid potentially hides a mine and
your goal is to find all the mines
without stepping on one and exploding
them and so the way you do this is you
click on one of these cells and it then
tells you whether there was a mine there
or not and if there wasn't a mind then
all is fine and as in this example here
you might see a little number that tells
you how many minds are in any adjacent
cells now in this case that doesn't help
me much because it tells me there's one
mind but but you know not a lot else so
let me click somewhere else to get a get
a bit of a start on this and you see oh
this was better I've clicked on an empty
uh cell here where there's no minus got
lucky
um but I got so lucky that I actually
found that there's lots of empty cells
everywhere around and it'll
automatically open all of those up and
how I can go and I can work out with
these numbers where the minds are now
the goal of this video isn't to explain
Minesweeper to you so I'm going to kind
of stop at this point as much as I love
playing Minesweeper and I'm going to
look a little bit at the code right so
let me close this Minesweeper
application here let's have a look at
the code so here you can see on the left
of the screen you can see all the
various pieces all the various files
that I've built to build this this
program now my super is by no stretch of
the imagination a complicated piece of
software it's still a fairly simple full
piece of software but you can still see
you know as I developed this I sort of
had to write quite a number of files
okay and if I look into some of these
files this is one of the classes it
happens to be the one where everything
starts and you can see there's a lot of
code going on now a key question you
might wonder about with Minesweeper is
what are the rules of Minesweeper
and how do I change them right if I want
to build a slightly different version of
Minesweeper or slightly different rules
how do I do this right because that's in
the end what you care about as a game
developer you care about the rules of
the game you don't necessarily care so
much about
how to explain to Windows or Linux or
Mac OS or Android
how to get the thing on the screen you
in the first instance you're interested
in designing the rules of the game and
you want to be able to see them and you
want to be able to change them the
problem with this code of course is
we've got nine classes or so here and
the rules could be anywhere in there
okay in fact there's all kinds all kind
of stuff in this code right so this code
here that we see here it's got stuff
about the menu it's got stuff about
initializing Fields but then in there if
I look at this again it creates tables
and it creates listeners to Mouse events
so again that's about user interaction
and not so much about the rules so all
kinds of things are intermixed right and
it's really difficult to find what the
rules of the game are okay in an mde
approach what we would take is we would
take a step back from this and we'd say
actually
let's not worry about all of these
details let's obstruct away from them
just like
Java abstracts away from the machine
code let's abstract away from that and
build ourselves a modeling language and
then write a model that captures only
the information that we care about
okay so let's look here at a different
way of representing Minesweeper in this
file here so this
is a little modeling language I built
and a little model in that modeling
language I built to describe Minesweeper
and in fact it turns out that from this
model I can generate automatically
all the Java code that's needed for for
running Minesweeper okay and what this
does is it has these these field
commands here which allow me to Define
What fields there are what rectangular
Fields let's open up one of those so the
easy field here it basically says well
it's 10 cells wide is 10 cells high and
then it's initialized using this fill
field thing which is defined down here
and it has takes one parameter which is
the number of Mines that we want to set
up in our in in our field and we're
setting this to 10. so in an easy field
we have it's 10 wide is 10 high and it
has contains 10 mines okay now the other
fields are set up with different sizes
Etc let's have a look at briefly at what
this feel field thing looks like well it
sort of says okay
I'm going to use various strategies for
initializing the field I'm going to
start by randomly initializing this many
elements cells in that list field with
mines then I'm going to use this context
rule to say I'm going to put ordering
mind cells anywhere where there is
already a mine cell somewhere and they
they're going to sit around that and the
bordering mind sells are the ones that
show these little numbers when you
discover them
and then everything else gets filled
with empty cells okay and that's the
basic things that you need to know about
setting up the Mind sweeper field right
so you don't need to know more you don't
need to care about how this setting up
of these cells actually happens or
anything like that you just want to say
that's the rules Okay so we've mentioned
these different types of cells so
obviously we need to Define them and
that's what the cell command is for
right so we can define an empty cell we
can define a bordering mind cell and we
can define a regular mind cell basically
all set up using these mind States thing
here because the key idea in this
modeling language is to say well
actually each of these little cells that
we have here has a little State machine
attached to it okay so it can be in one
of a number of states and depending on
what the user does with the cell and
depending on maybe what else happens it
might change its state okay and so it's
useful to just basically be able to do
the rules of the game I guess are what
states there are and what the
transitions between those data and so we
Define what this date machine is here
using this mind stage thing here and you
can see that pretty much this the state
machine is the same for empty cells mind
cells bordering mind cells because
essentially they react to user input in
the same way they go from this
undiscovered State this hidden state so
a discovered State and maybe you can add
a flag state if you wanted to
um the only difference is that they
might be showing slightly different
things on one they are discovered and
there might be a different thing that
happens right when you click on the mine
things will explode when you click not
don't click on a mine nothing will
happen other than discovering the cell
and then we say okay well what are the
states well it starts with this hidden
State and what's important about the
State Board what's important is what it
looks like it looks like a button with
no text on it like an empty button and
what happens when you click on it or
when other things happen right so
transitions that move it to another
state but now we can do things here
right quite easily we can say oh
actually
let's not go to the flat State when you
right click on on the cell let's forbid
that let's not introduce this flaxseed
right the flag state is where you can
right click on a cell and you can sort
of put a little marker there to kind of
go I think there might be a mind here
but I'm not quite sure and if I save
this here
then it regenerates code for me and then
let me just run this and there we are
there is my Minesweeper and now I can
try and right click on this but
nothing's going to happen
but I can continue to sort of left click
and play the game
okay and if I make this thing available
again here regenerates all of this code
for me and I can run it again and now I
should be able to right click on here
see and I've got the flag this cell here
to say there might be a mine there I'm
not quite sure okay so so really easily
I've just changed the rules directly in
this imagine if I had had to try and do
that in my Java code I would have
probably had to touch three or five four
files remember the changes that I made
make sure that I make them consistently
Etc none of which I had to worry about
in this case okay another thing that I
get is and you might have spotted that
briefly if I comment this out again for
a moment here you will see suddenly this
part of the of my model gets this yellow
underline I go on this this says this
state cannot be reached so this is only
possible because in my model I have made
it explicit that there's this idea of a
state and that there's this idea of
things moving between states and
therefore clearly it's not a good thing
if it's if I've defined a state I cannot
be reached but because I've got these
things explicit in my language
I can actually do this analysis and I
can actually check for it and I can give
better feedback to people developing
these things if this was a language I'll
only allowed me to build minesweep but
it'd be a bit silly
okay so the trick to doing mde is to
build languages that meet get find that
sort of Sweet Spot between being
specific enough
that that the abstractions are useful to
a particular group of people
and that they allow us to do
give compact expressions of the things
that we actually care about
and allow us to do useful analysis like
invalidations like the one that I've
just shown
while not being so specific and narrow
that we can only write ever write one
program in the language okay and finding
that kind of balance is a tricky thing
and so one other thing you can for
example Define with this language is
this game of life here we're going to
scale up I mean you know obviously for a
simple cell program like this you can
see this working but we've got programs
out there with millions of lines of code
haven't we I mean how how would it
change that sort of development no
actually actually it scales up really
well right because because what it does
is effectively reduce the number of
lines of code that you're right right so
every line of code I've written here in
my modeling language translates into n
lines of code I'm not quite that many
perhaps in this example but potentially
quite a few lines of code in uh in in
the real sort of programming language
but are you not making it so it's less
less flexible process by by you know
having to write a language for each one
and then obviously constraining people
within the what that language can do yes
of course of course right so you are
reducing flexibility
um but that's that's always been true
right in this process well so so there
are things you can write an assembler
that are
difficult or impossible to ride in a
higher level programming language but
that's not necessarily a bad thing right
because more often than not what it
actually does is
reduce the number of ways in which you
can shoot yourself in the foot
we'd like to thank scalar for supporting
this computer file video if you like me
love to learn something new then you're
going to love scalar as a resource for
upskilling they cater to everyone no
matter what skill level which means that
you're going to get a lot out of their
programs whether it's their interview
hacks the mentorships or curated
computer science courses every techie
should know about scalar scalar's
programs are flexible and care for you
choose a starting point based on your
expertise and become a part of their
thriving community
it's easy to get started you can take
part in a free live class by simply
following the link in the video
description the live classes are clear
and accessible and you can simply sign
up for whichever you fancy you want to
learn the basics of machine learning in
under 20 minutes build a chat bot or
take a course in the fundamentals of
system design they have it all if you
watch this video because you're already
a coder then take your coding to the
next level with a scalar program
tailored to your existing expertise a
look at the website the scalar website
shows scalar alumni work at top Global
corporations and you can see their
programs and events in software
development and data science remember
there's a link in the video description
and thanks again to Scala for supporting
this computer file video